[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much for coming
to my talk my name is nicole provenza
and i'm a postdoctoral fellow and senior
chef's lab at baylor college of medicine
and today i'll be presenting about our
work on long-term ecological assessment
of intracranial electrophysiology
synchronized to behavioral markers and
obsessive compulsive disorder
so the overarching goal of my work in
this work is to improve the efficacy of
deep brain stimulation for obsessive
compulsive disorder or ocd
so ocd is a psychiatric illness marked
by obsessions which are recurrent
distressing thoughts and compulsions
which are repetitive ritualistic
behaviors
it affects two to three percent of the
u.s population
first line treatments include medication
and psychotherapy but they don't work
for everyone 10 to 20 percent of ocd
patients are treatment resistant
and we know that deep brain stimulation
targeted to the eventual capsule
eventual striatum or vcvs region
improves ocd symptoms in 50 to 70 of
these refractory cases
one of the reasons that gbs might not be
100 effective today is that
dbs amplitude is constant but symptoms
aren't so if stimulation amplitude is
set too low we might still see ocd
symptoms but if stimulation amplitude is
set too high we might see side effects
of
cbs including hypomania
so during a dbs programming session the
goal is really to find the amplitude
that reduces symptoms without causing
side effects so it's kind of like a
sweet spot but the problem is
the sweet spot can change over time
depending how symptoms are fluctuating
the current dbf paradigm isn't really
set up to handle those fluctuations
today
dbs is
an open loop where simulation parameters
are chosen during visits to the
clinician's office that take place weeks
months apart so the patient might come
into the office for a pbs programming
session
cbs is turned on for the first time and
they might say they think they feel
better but then they go home and they
experience
um side effects of vcvs cbs or even new
ocd symptoms and weeks to months later
they come back into the clinician's
office for another round of pbs
optimization
and they don't feel better anymore
so
tonic stimulation in this open move
paradigm really fails to address the
dynamic nature of ocd symptoms
and side effects that may fluctuate over
minutes to days in between these
clinical physics so we're proposing that
automatic detection of mental states
related to symptoms and side effects
might improve efficacy of dbs for ocd
what this would look like is
we would
record neural signals continuously from
the brain use those signals to classify
relevant brain states such as an
obsessive-compulsive symptom state
and then control stimulation parameters
accordingly to relieve symptoms
so there are several key challenges that
need to be addressed in order to get
here and to realize an adaptive dbs
system for ocd
the first two
involves better characterizing symptom
state so first there's a lack of
established physical readouts of symptom
state in ocd and other psychiatric
disorders
next there's uncertainty in how ocd
symptoms vary over time at home
and the next one involves neural
biomarker identification for
classification of relevant brain states
so today there's no putative neural
biomarker for any psychiatric disorder
and
until recently we didn't have the
ability to record intracranial neural
data at home
and since home is where these symptoms
and side effects are taking place
this is really where we should be
identifying our biomarker so we need the
ability to detect neural biomarkers
outside of a controlled clinical setting
so we recently published a paper in
nature medicine that tackles those three
challenges from the previous slide most
notably the ability to detect spinal
markers outside of a controlled clinical
setting and as you can see from this
really long list of authors this work is
part of a collaborative um effort on an
nih uh three effort between baylor
college of medicine the university of
pittsburgh and brown university which is
my alma mater
where the overarching goal is to develop
adaptive deep brain stimulation for ocd
so
in this work i'll talk about our first
five study participants who all referred
to as p1 through p5 uh the first two p1
and p2 were implanted with the medtronic
xt about pc plus s and the
last row three were implanted with the
summit rc plus s
so across these five participants
there's some overlap in principle ocd
symptoms um but the ocd symptoms really
manifest in different ways across each
of these individuals
and i want to make note of the fact that
all five participants are responders to
dds treatment
and the summit rc process
is
rechargeable and allows for wireless
data transmission
and that enables streaming of time
domain intracranial electrophysiology
both in the clinic and at home and this
is something that's not possible with
the pc plus death system or
um
any other therapeutic dds platform
that's currently available so in this
talk i'll focus on the data gathered
from the three participants implanted
with the senate rt process p3 p4 and p5
so
during dbs surgery the leads were
replaced in either the bad nucleus
striat terminus the bnst
or the ventral striatum
based on awake intraoperative testing
so here i'm showing p4 as an example
where the tip of the right lead was
targeted to the bad nucleus strata
terminalis which is just posterior to
the anterior commissure
um
and the anterior commissure here is the
orange fiber tract highlighted on the
slice
and the tip of the left weed was
targeted to the ventral striatum which
is just anterior to the anterior
commissure
the stimulation and sensing contacts are
indicated by the color of each of the
four spheres
here
where the sensing contacts are the green
ones that flank the red simulation
contact
and the highest contact on both sides um
was unused
and i want to acknowledge write the
methora and known to who were both
instrumental in terms of
putting these nice brain figures
together
so after surgery the participants
returned bi-weekly to monthly to the
clinic for gds programming adjustments
and some other behavioral and
electrophysiological testing
so here i'm showing clinical outcomes
for p4
on that schedule where the participant
returned to the clinic
so gvs surgery and the first cbs
programming session are marked by the
vertical black lines with dbs on at time
zero
and i first want to draw your attention
to the y box
which is the green line which stands for
the yale brown obsessive compulsive
scale it's the gold standard clinical
assessment for diagnosing ocp
so the higher the y box the more severe
the ocd symptoms
the star marks the point at which the
participant became a responder to dbs
according to ybox in about 30 weeks
um next i want to draw your attention to
the young's mania rating scale so the
pink line which is used to assess
hypomania
as a potential side effect of vcds cvs
which you can see is fluctuating over
time
the other two scales here are the y box
2 the blue line which is another measure
of ocd symptoms and
hdrs a measure of depression
symptoms
so we have data
through these clinical scales
on how the participant is doing when
they come into the clinic on about a
monthly basis
and these clinical skills typically
evaluate
symptoms over the course of the previous
two weeks but one big question we need
to answer in order to find a robust
neural biomarker is how is the
participant doing in between clinical
visits
and how are the symptoms changing on a
daily or a moment-to-moment basis in
natural environments
so the what's going on in between visits
question is really what we're trying to
get out with this work
so
to get at that question
we're streaming intracranial lfp
both in the clinic and at home and it's
time synced with
behaviors
so in the clinic we're able to estimate
changes in assets in response to
changing simulation parameters over
short time scales by estimating positive
affects via
automatic facial affect recognition or
affar
and at home we've made an effort to
maximize the quality and utility of our
recordings by asking participants to
record in a in a really wide range of
scenarios they record just daily doing
whatever they would be doing normally
during exposure and response prevention
or erp therapy during sleep during
behavioral tests and during multi-day
sprint recordings which are just long
recordings that happen over the course
of multiple days with breaks for
recharging
participants can control their own
recordings at home by using a
patient-facing application
which was developed by researchers and
software engineers at brown university
david chang fernando jaylin and bradford
rohr
and participants can launch behavioral
tasks
from the playground tab of the reporting
application and there are also automatic
automatic impedance checks at the start
of each recording
so each time the participants do
recordings we ask them to rate their
intensity of ocd symptoms
using a phone application tailored for
ocd
so
in this talk i'll be focusing on the
self-reported intensity ratings
which is
rated by using the slider shown on the
phone
from 0 to 10
and the participants are also rating
mood sleep and food intake
so to give you an idea of what the first
programming session might look like i'll
show a video of participant p5
so here we're recording from top to
bottom here
in the right column
heart rate
through ecg and blood volume pulse
64 channels of eeg
and then we have lsp and acceleration
from the rc plus s along with
dbs amplitude adjustments
so this video of the participant's face
was used to estimate positive
affect or positive valence on a zero to
five scale based on the intensity of two
different facial action units related to
cheek breathing and lip stretching
that happens during a smile
so as you watch the video look for
positive aspects to increase or decrease
with smiles as dbs amplitude changes
you guys are shaking my body
my inside's not shaking
we're back to where we were okay it's
not shaking how weird
it would literally when you turned it
off i didn't even realize that it went
back to doing this on that i didn't know
i was doing that it's not doing that
right now
oh my gosh
it's like the best thing ever
that it's that's cool
cool
weird
it's not like i'm not internally
trembling like fear-wise
it's different
that's probably the biggest thing i can
feel different is there's not like a
other than just feeling like
a breeze feeling but other than that
those are the two why are you two
because it feels nice that i'm not
shaking and i didn't even know i was
shaking
like it feels it's a good thing like i
didn't realize it until you turned it
off and it like
my stomach inside felt like it was doing
this i was like oh am i more anxious
again like why is that
wow
okay
guys this is so freaking cool
holy crap
so as we just saw this was a really
emotional and happy moment for this
patient uh this is the first time she
felt released in a really long time and
you can actually see this emotion
getting picked up in the data so to take
a second look at that we're estimating
positive aspect intensity in response to
changing stimulation parameters and here
we saw a peak in positive affect a smile
uh during the portion of programming
um when stimulation was increasing
simulation amplitude was increasing from
0 to 4.5 milliamps in steps of 0.5
billion so in the future we're really
excited to use this data to predict
positive affects based on
changes in the neural data
so at home we're monitoring symptoms in
between clinical visits and over longer
time scales so these plots show the
self-reported intensity of ocd symptoms
um that the participants are reporting
using the roon application on a scale of
so from top to bottom we have
participants p3 p4 and p5 and the
colored points are the symbol intensity
readings and the solid line shows the y
box 2 score where higher y box 2 means
more severe ocd
so as i mentioned all three participants
are responders
and the time point at which they became
responders is indicated by these stars
and so p3 and p5 only really recently
reached responder status but p4 who
reached responder status at 30 weeks
after dbs on continues to have pretty
wide variation in symptom severity over
days
and
we find this variation really
interesting because it shows that even
after responder criteria is met
there are still good days and bad days
and symptoms are still fluctuating
and this point acts as further
motivation for developing an adaptive
dbs system that can respond to these
fluctuations and symptoms and
reduce those symptom intensity ratings
in the long term
so each time the participants do a
recording again we ask them to report
their intensity vocabulary symptoms
using that phone application so we can
associate
each recording that they do with a
particular symptom level and this bar
chart summarizes the amount of data and
hours that we've collected
across each symptom intensity level
along with how much data we've collected
during behavioral tasks
during explosion response prevention
therapy and
totally requested over a thousand hours
of lsp across these three participants
and notice that the majority of the data
has been collected um by p4 so this teal
color
this participant has been in the study
the longest and
most of the data
collected by t4 is associated with
symptom intensities of below 3 out of
10.
so even though this participant reported
a wide range of ocd symptoms
after responder status as they showed on
the last slide
they're really only doing recordings of
neural data when they're feeling well
we generally notice
that this is a trend across participants
which speaks to an underlying reporting
bias where participants are more likely
to engage with the technology when
they're feeling well than
than when they're feeling bad
so we're also doing
multi-day sprint recordings
which are long recordings over multiple
days where ideally the only breaks in
recording are for recharging
so here i'm showing an example sprint
recording where participant p4
recorded for over 30 consecutive hours
with a few breaks and the participant
recorded heart rate and acceleration
on the apple watch lsp and acceleration
on the rc profess and
they submitted ocd syndrome intensity
readings on about an hourly basis
except for during sleep
and the 90 data 90 um
seconds of data that i'm showing here is
just an example of each of these data
streams
so p4
did one three-day sprint recording where
there were natural exposures to ocd
triggers on days one and two
and this recording really stood out to
us as a good opportunity for analysis
because we don't often see such wide
fluctuation in logged ocd symptoms
within the same long reporting
and our goal is to develop a classifier
that distinguishes between low symptoms
and high symptoms so in order to do that
we need to collect a lot of data
associated with both states
so lft availability over the 80 hours
here is shown by the orange shading and
self-reported intensity of ocd symptoms
is shown on the y-axis so to analyze the
lsp data i computed special power
in different frequency bands of interest
for the two-minute segment of data
around each symptom intensity rating
which of the points in the plot
and if there is a change in neural
activity in the ventral striatum during
symptom provocations
we should be able to pick that up in
spectral power of lfp
so here i'm showing results from that
analysis
sexual power versus symptom intensity
for
going across delta band theta band alpha
band beta and gamma bands
for left in the first row
um and right
in the second row bcbi
and i found that bcbs spectral power
shows correlations with ocd symptom
intensity where the correlation between
symptoms and delta-van power showed the
strongest correlation
and theta alpha beta and gamma given
power showed relatively weaker
correlations
so another opportunity to record neural
data during ocd exposures and variable
symptom intensities is during exposure
and response prevention or erp therapy
so the exposure in erp refers to
exposing yourself to the thoughts images
objects and situations that make you
anxious or start your obsessions
whereas the response prevention part of
erp refers to making a choice not to do
a compulsive behavior once the anxiety
or obsessions have been triggered and
all of this is done under the guidance
of therapists
so during the two-month cognitive
behavioral therapy booster phase of our
study
each participant does 13 erp teletherapy
sessions
and
this chart just shows the data streams
available for each one of those sessions
over the two months for p4 and i boxed
out this particular session
of interest that i'll show you a video
clip from on the next slide um here the
exposure was a work
or an image of a word on a finger and
you can see the participant is at home
and the therapist is in the office and
this plot shows heart rate collected
over the whole session and also
throughout the session the participants
have to verbally rate their subjective
units as distressed or substrating
um
and that tracks with the black line so
the video clip i'll show in the next
slide corresponds to the gray shaded
area on that spot
where the
where the introduction of the exposure
happens at the beginning of the clip and
is marked by this vertical black line on
the plot
so the participant that you'll see in
this video has very severe
ocd specific to contamination and the
thought of having a wart is really
distressing so the image helps to
facilitate thoughts about having a wart
recording i'm recording on the watch as
well
can you see this okay
yeah
okay so right here is where we're
talking yeah yeah let's see it zero to
ten
eight point five
oh gosh
and now i'm looking at my i'm looking at
my own hands
that's good
for one of those
so hero cd's concerned that you could
have one right now
yeah
okay
this is really good work i know that
this is uh this was a huge trigger
even that you're willing to con even
though you're willing to look at this to
purposely look at this like that's
that's awesome let's keep rolling with
this so what are we doing why is this
wrong and dangerous and how are we just
gonna resist those urges we're not
correcting this
yeah okay
you can still see me right yep
huh yeah okay yeah i can
ah
suds
8.5 still very strong 8.5 oh god
so this participant uh identified
thinking about worse as a rather
difficult exposure and actually had to
complete a number of contamination
related exposures over many weeks to
even build up to this so this is a
really significant um
session for this participant
um
so over all the erp sessions across all
three participants we saw a high range
of subjective units of stress or studs
ratings
throughout this session and for this
reason llc recordings during erp
teletherapy present a really unique
opportunity to capture neural data
during fluctuations and symptoms
severity
so as an example i'll show results from
analysis similar to the analysis of the
sprint reporting i already showed using
this session that i've boxed out here
for the same participant in q4
so
here the subs readings range from 3 to
7.5 throughout the erp session and the
vertical black lines show the time point
uh where each exposure began and as you
can see
there is some habituation after each
exposure according to the suds ratings
plotted so i analyzed lsp data in the
same way as before by computing special
power and frequency bands of interest
for each two minute segment around each
symptom intensity rating
and here you can also see some
interesting correlations between studs
and spectral power across frequency
bands
so while delta van power did not show
the strongest correlation here of all
the bands
we did find that the relationship
between delta band power and symptoms
was preserved across planned exposures
during erp
and natural exposures during the sprint
reporting in p4
so the recording platform that i've
described um
enables this type of naturalistic
analysis and
future work will determine the degree of
the consistency of these brain behavior
relationships across patients and their
potential as biomarkers for abs
applications
so to summarize the significance of this
work
for the first time in patients with a
psychiatric disorder we demonstrate the
utility of at home intracranial
recordings which vastly increase the
quantity and ecological validity of the
recorded data we captured over a
thousand hours of lsp data at home
across different symptom levels
and we demonstrate the ability to
measure vcbs spectral power during
natural and planned ocd symptom
provocations at home
using that data we identified delta band
power as a candidate biomarker of high
intensity of ocd symptoms
and continued opportunities for
long-term naturalistic intracranial
electrophysiological recordings
we hope this will propel biomarker
discovery for ocd and other psychiatric
disorders
so next i'll talk about a few emerging
challenges that i think the field faces
so we really need to identify robust
behavioral biomarkers
the utility of self-reported assessments
like intensity of ocd
symptoms are limited as they rely on
patient insight into their own
psychological state which is variable so
we really need enhanced passive
behavioral state monitoring
we also really need to automate
electrophysiological
data collection
more than half of lsp data collected for
participant p4 is associated with
symptom intensity ratings below 2 out of
10. so
until lsp recordings can be triggered
without participant input
they'll be subject to the participants
motivation anxiety and mood
so we need to decrease participant
burden and automate data collection
and lastly
we need to harness network connectivity
estimates
obsessive convulsive behaviors and
implicate symptomatic networks
so we need to increase the cover of our
coverage of our approach to a few
key areas including
the orbitofrontal cortex or anterior
cingulate cortex
by increasing the coverage our ability
to identify a biomarker and design an
adaptive dbs system would improve
leading to better outcomes for severe
cases of ocd
and so
in the next phase of this clinical trial
we're using electrocorticography or ecos
to record from the orbitofrontal cortex
in addition to the eventual striatum
so the hypothesis is um that oc symptoms
result from hyperactive connectivity
between the ventral striatum and the ofc
um and this hypothesis is supported by
both imaging studies and
characterization of functional pathways
so we're really excited uh to see how
connectivity may be related to changing
ocd symptom states
so in closing i'd like to acknowledge my
pi samir shaft my thesis advisor
in grad school david borton uh the pi of
the uhd study wayne goodman and i'd also
like to thank our collaborators at the
university of pittsburgh jeff cohen's
team
for their
computer vision estimates of facial
affect and i want to thank the open mind
consortium for their support throughout
data collection and with that i would
love to take any questions
thank you
you